right now it's like it's like you're
kind of living and delusion everyone's
like you know maybe it's not a good look
and you're like well it's just how I am
I feel like me saying my pussy's tight
it isn't determine it doesn't determine
how many men I've slept with if I'm a
hoe do I go out and suck dick every week
I want to hear from them what are you
hey blessing what do you what do you
what do you think when a woman says that
canceled okay what do you what do you
think when a woman says that I pretty
much the same probably just want to
sample it just to see if it's time but
imagine he could never though
difference between
you know what I mean but like I'm saying
if you're saying that out there all
right let me test it and see if this and
they could never that's the thing that's
why I'm so confident